حياكم الله بعد سنوات من الهدوء بين
القوات الامريكيه والجماعات المسلحه
المدعومه من ايران في سوريا تحول الشرق
السوريه الى ساحه للمواجهه بين طهران و
واشنطن في تغير مفاجئ لقواعد الاشتباك وفق
تقارير اعلاميه التصعيد الذي بدا الخميس
الماضيه مع هجوم بطائره مسيره ونتج عنه
مقتل متعاقد امريكي واصابه اربعه جنود
امريكيين في احدى القواعد بريف الحسكه قرب
الحدود العراقيه سرعت واشنطن الى الرد
بقصف جوي على منشات مرتبطه بمجموعات تابعه
للحرس الثوري ما اسفر عن مقتل 19 مسلحا
حسب حصيله للمرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
ورغم ان المجموعات المواليه لايران في
ريفي دير الزور استهدفت سابقا قواعد
عسكريه امريكيه في المنطقه الا ان تلك
الهجمات لم تكن مؤثره وافقى خبراء فان هذه
الاستهدافات الامريكيه الايرانيه
المتبادله تشير الى ان
حال الهدوء النسبي بين الطرفين اخذ منحا
جديدا ينذر بمواجهه اوسع للنطاق
[موسيقى]
المتحدث باسم المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
الايراني كيفان خصراوي
الذرائع لمهاجمه القواعد التي تم انشاؤها
بناء على طلب دمشق ستقابل برد سريع
القواعد انشئت للتصدي للارهاب وعناصر داعش
رويترز طهران تعتبر القوات الامريكيه في
سوريا قوات محتله
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لا نسعى لصراع
مع طهران لكن واشنطن ستتصرف بقوه لحمايه
الامريكيين
ينضم الينا من امستردام عبر سكايب يعقوب
سعيد الباحث في شان الايراني ومن واشنطن
عبر سكايب ايضا ديفيد بولوك المستشار
السابق في وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه اهلا
بكم يعني بدايه ليبدا من واشنطن عبر سكايب
سيده بولوك هل هذا حادث عابر ام نهج جديد
تتبعه الاداره الامريكيه
بصراحه كامله انا اعتقد انه الجواب البسيط
لا انا اعتقد انه نحن كنار تلك الهجومات
المتبادله من زمان في اراضي السوريه ولكن
الحقيقه انه
الماء يخالف
الماضي انا اعتقد هو قتل
مواطن امريكي ولذلك نحن كنا رد فعل قوي
امريكي على هذا
هجومات
وكما نحن كنا نرى في الماضي في سنتين
الاخيرتين كما قال الجنرال مارك ميلي
ووزير الدفاع الامريكي
وكما كما قال الرئيس الامريكي نحن
ندافئ عن الذات ونحن
موثيرون على حمايه الامريكيين في كل مكان
في العالم طيب سيد يعقوب سعيد الباحث في
الشان الايراني هل هذا يعتبر امتداد لهذه
المواجهه بين الطرفين على اراد سوريه ام
تغير لقواعد الاشتباك بينهما الان
تحيه طيبه لك ولمشاهدين قناه العربيه
وكذلك في الحقيقه ما يميز هذه المواجهاتنا
الميليشيات المواليه والمدعومه من ايران
استخدمت مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع في هذه
الضربات
تقاعد الامريكيه هذا الامر لم يحدث
في سمى ندر كان يحصل دائما في العراق ولكن
يبدو ان الاراضي السوريه تبدو فعلا هي
الساحه الانسب لنقل مواجهات المحدوده بين
ايران والولايات المتحده اليها بدل العراق
يعني البلد اللي شكل لسنوات في الحقيقه
ساحه ساحه مواجهه بين اذرع ايران والقواعد
الامريكيه خاصه ان الميليشيات الولائيه
الان في العراق قد خفضت منسوب العداء
للولايات المتحده في خطاب قادتها الاخيره
ابن السبب وراء ذلك ورغبتهم بعدم احراج
حكومه السودان مدعوم من اطار التنسيقي
لذلك اعتقد بان اليوم
تجد بان الحرس الثوري الايراني هو من يريد
ان يشكل ساحه بديله لهذه الساحه العراقيه
وهي سوريا لاستهداف المناطق في الحقيقه
هذه الاستهداف القاعده الامريكيه سيد هل
تتفق مع ضيفي حينما يقول بانه فقط المكان
والمشهد مستمر لكن المكان هو من تغير نقله
من العراقي الى سوريا
هذا من الممكن الصراحه انا اتفق مع هذا
التقييم الواقعي ان نحن نحن نرى الان
مرحله
او نعم من الهدوء في العراق بالمقارنه الى
الماضي
ولكن انا لا اتوقد تسعيد جوهري في سوريا
في هذه النقطه انا اخالف الى احد ما
اعتقين زميلنا لماذا لا تعتبره تصعيد
جوهري لماذا تعتبره تصعيد مؤقت على الاقل
لان حسب قول الرئيس جو بايدن نفسه لما قال
نحن لا نافعي مواجهه عسكريه ضد ايران
كما نحن كما انا اقرا وانا افهم تصريحات
ايران في نفس الوقت انه
ليس هناك رغبه لمواجهه عسكريه واسعه بين
ايران من احلى وامريكا من ناحيه اخرى ولكن
هناك تحرش يعني
ايراني وربما رد امريكي قالها بكل وضوح
انهم جاهزون لردع اي هجمات ضد القوات
الامريكيه
لا قتل مواطن امريكي لا شك انه نحن سوف
نرى رد فعل قوي امريكي على تلك هجمات
الايرانيه او من قبل علمليشيات المواليه
ايران سواء كان في العراق او في سوريا او
في الخليج او في اي مكان طيب
يعني سيد يعقوب اليوم حينما ان نتحدث عن
تصعيد ليس فقط على الساحه انما تصعيد
اعلامي من الطرفين هذه اللغه ما بين
الاداره الامريكيه وحتى ما تقوله ايران من
ان الحرس الثوري او ايران لديها اليد طوله
هناك في سوريا
نعم هو في الحقيقه اذا ما راقبنا
المواجهات التي وقعت خلال الايام الماضيه
نجد بين الرد الامريكي محدود يعني لا
يتواخذ تصعيد مع الطرف الايراني يقول انه
لو قتل كان هناك تصعيد اكبر وهي انا انا
قلت تصحيح او ارد اكبر رد اكبر
طيب اعتقد بانه هذا الامر ايضا اكده بايدن
اعتقد باننا لسنا امام تصعيد امريكي بل
تصعيد ايراني لمواجهه وهو في الحقيقه
اليوم الذي حدث هو ليس لا يوجد تصعيد
امريكي بل تصعيد ايراني ورد امريكي يعتقد
بين التصعيد الامريكي سيكون مرهود مرهون
برد هذه الميليشيات المواليه والمدعومه من
نظام الايراني عادل يعني اليوم نحن
هذه المواجهات تتوقف لا تتوقف عند هذا
الحد لان اليوم لا توجد رؤيه واضحه متفق
عليها من قبل نظام الايراني لشكل السياسه
الخارجيه الايرانيه بعد التطبيع العلاقات
مع الدول العربيه
[موسيقى]
لابد من الاشاره للتسجيلات وزير الخارجيه
الايراني السابق ظريف عندما اشار الى
مساري الميدان والدبلوماسيه في تحديد
السياسه الخارجيه الايرانيه الميدان او
ساحه المعركه المتمثله بكيان الحرس الثوري
الغاضب والممتعر من هذه الاتفاقيات في
الحقيقه اللي هي قد تحدد نفوذه في المنطقه
على المستوى البعيد وبين الدبلوماسيه
الايرانيه المتمثله بالحكومه او مجلس
الامن القومي اللي يريد الذهاب لتهدئه
الاوضاع في الاقليم بشكل مؤقت لكي تعالج
ازماتها الاقتصاديه والامنيه الداخليا لكن
اعتقد بان الهدف الاساسي من هذه الضربه هو
توجيه رساله من الحرس الثوري بانه يريد ان
يوصل رساله مفاتها بين النظام لازال يمتلك
اوراقا يمكنه استخدامه لتاجيل الاوضاع في
المنطقه بين الحرس الثوري ما زال موجود في
هذه المنطقه وما زال فاعل وقادر على
التاثير بها وكما تقول ايران لديها اليد
الطول في سوريا لكن سيد بولوك اليوم حينما
نتحدث عن قبل قليل كنا نتحدث عن تحرش
ايراني بالقوات الامريكيه في سوريا
باعتقادك ماذا تريد ايران هل تريد الضغط
على الولايات المتحده ام تريد ان تقول لها
انا هنا الدخول الى هذه المنطقه يكمن عبر
البوابه الايرانيه
سؤال جيد
لكن الجواب غير واضح بعيد انا بصراحه
كاميرا انا لا افهم
النوايا الايرانيه بشكل واضح وانا اعتقد
ان ربما كما قال الزميير المحترم هناك نوع
من خلافات داخل النظام الايراني بين على
سبيل المثال الوزاره الخارجيه من ناحيه
والحرس الثوري الايراني من ناحيه اخرى او
القوات الامنيه الايرانيه وطبعا في نهايه
الامر المرشده لا على هو صاحب القرار وانا
اعتقد انه
ربما هو يريد ان يقول للعالم نحن
في مسار الان كما قالها الزميل
التطبيع العلاقات مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
والكويت والامارات العربيه المتحده وكذا
وكذا ولكن في نفس الوقت
ما زالت امريكا العدو الشيطان
من قبل او او في كما هو تحت الطاوله يعني
الملف النووي ايضا
شيطان اذا ما جاز التعبير بالنسبه
للايرانيين هل هي تريد ان تضغط هنا حتى
يتم المعادله هناك طيب اذا كانت الضبابيه
في المشهد الايراني الموقف الامريكي كيف
تراه
الملف النووي
مجمد
وانا اعتقد انه للاسف الشديد نحن التقارب
ايراني الى مكاسبه قنبله نوويه فعاليه من
ناحيه وتردد امريكي بالنسبه
للمواجهه هذه الخطوره التي انا اعتقد تهدد
مصالح العرب والامريكان في نفس الوقت في
المنطقه بشكل عام هذه انا اعتقد المشهد
الحزين والخطير الذي نحن نراه الان وربما
الهجومات ضد القوات الامريكيه في سوريا
بشكل هكذا محدود من قبل الميليشيات
المواليه لايران نامن تشويش
المعنى انه نحن نفضل التركز على
الهجومات
بصواريخ او بالمسيرات بدلا
عن التركز عن الخطوره النوويه الاعلى من
قبل النظام في طهران طيب شكرا جزيلا يا
سيده ديفيد بولوك المستشار السابق في
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه شكر موصول ايضا
ليعقوب سعيد الباحث في شان الايراني شكرا
جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]